[Applause]
Yeah. Uh as to your question of recip or
what you said about reciprocity,
uh at what point do you think we can
seriously engage the Muslim world about
reciprocity? Not just in terms of
hypersensitivity towards insult, but
actually allowing churches and
synagogues to be built in Saudi Arabia
and other Muslim countries. Actually
allowing churches, for example, to
expand according to the needs of the
demographics, which is not possible in a
Muslim land. uh and uh in general uh
that that in Muslim countries that
Muslims should provide the same kind of
respect for other faiths that they
expect to be provided to them in the
United States and in Western countries.
I'm all for that. Honestly, I don't see
it happening. Uh non-Muslims and Muslim
countries live under dimitude, their
subclass status. They're denied basic
human rights. Uh I think there's a lot
listen even mus mo mo moderate Muslims
uh they suffer at the hands of the uh
fundamentalists
most egregiously most egregiously I mean
how many were slaughtered in the jihad
in Dwar and Sudan and again this
misrepresentation of the war in in in
Sudan they never discuss it in the terms
of and the motivation of what it is and
that is jihad
So if you have any ideas when the Saudis
are going to big build a big sh I want
to go. So you let me Well, you know,
it's interesting to note that at the
time of Muhammad, there were three very
uh large Jewish tribes in Medina, the uh
Banu Nadir, Banu Kanuka, and Banukura.
And so uh they should be accorded a
right of return, I think. But uh
in any case uh the the the ground zero
mosque proponents, they tend to try to
slap down this argument by saying, "So
you're acting as if the United States
ought to behave like Saudi Arabia and
deny religious freedom." No, no, no, no,
no.
This is the question here that if
Muslims are demanding rights in the
United States that the states they came
from are not willing to accord to their
non-Muslim citizens, then this ought to
be an opportunity for the United States
government to put pressure upon those
governments to inc improve their human
rights record.
That's all.
Okay. Um, you know, I find it ironic
that you're sitting up here talking
about freedom of speech and you start
off this question and answer period with
a lecture telling people to keep it
chilled. But, um, but I don't know. Let
we are adults here. We don't need I'll
come to your talk. Set it up. Oh, I'll
be more than happy to invite you, babe.
Great. So, uh, here's the thing I got an
issue with. Um, you brought up the
mosque. Um, how far is far away? How far
far enough? You say a couple of blocks.
Um,
I went to the August 22nd one. I know
you didn't have anything to do with that
uh rally. The August 22nd. I know I know
you didn't have anything to do with
that. And I knew you were asking me
about the ones I did. And I am going to
talk about the one you did, the one on
September 11th. Um, I know that you have
been involved with uh trying to prevent
the public school in 2007 from being
built. That's far enough away. Um, we
had the Islamic the Islamic public
school. I believe in separation of
church and state. I believe in
separation of mosque and state. Down the
line, it would be if it was Jewish, if
it was I don't believe public taxpayer
dollar should be used uh to build an
Islamic Okay, fair enough. Fair enough.
But I'm not done. I am not done.
We have moss and Islamic centers all
over this country. Yeah. Being um being
threatened, people trying to shut it
down. Whether you're talking about
what's going on in Manhattan or Michigan
or California, Tennessee, and we're also
talking about even in England. And on
top of that, oh, hold on. No, you're
throwing too many things happen. You got
to let me finish. You got to let me
finish. The mosques mosques are not
being Wait. Mosques are not being
protested. No, you can't just throw
stuff out there that's not true.
Specifically, radical mosques that are
tied to the Muslim Brotherhood. Radical
mosques. In Staten Island, it was the
Muslim-American Society. in Brooklyn.
It's the Muslim American Society, the
public face of the Muslim Brotherhood
since 1993. Mosques are not being
protested. And by the way, according to
the FBI last week, uh, hate crimes
against Muslims are their lowest level
since 2001. So, so you know, color me
skeptical here. I got another issue.
What's up with this English Defense
League? What's up? You got Are you
supportive of them? I I absolutely
support anyone who's standing up for
basic freedoms in their country. those
boys. The only thing that separates them
from being Nazis is that they changed
Jew from Jew to Muslim. They do
everything else but even associated.
This is a narrative. This is a
narrative. And like I said, like Robert
said, get your own room. The English
Defense League is um is is a bunch of
lads that lads a lads. That that's
that's what they call themselves. By the
way, the group started in June of last
year, 2009. when Muslims were uh
berating returning soldiers, calling
them baby killers and murderers. And so
this group started to protest that kind
of behavior. They are not violent. They
only they march against Islamic
supremacism. They march against Now, am
I tied to them? No. Am I am groups uh in
any way, shape, or no. Do I write them
checks? No. Do I believe they have a
right to fight for their basic freedoms
in the UK? Yes. Yes, I do. And did the
leader get kicked out of this country
when he tried to go to your house? Yes.
Did the members of that organization get
the hotel room?
Who raided their hotel rooms? Who raided
their hotel room? Oh, you did not.
No. I Who raided all over the news? All
over the house. Who Who raided it? You
tell me these boys were victims and
you're blaming you're blaming the
victims. They were victimized by
something. Who raided their rooms?
Oh, please. Okay, we need to move on to
the next question. Next question.
Yeah.
No, it's not that. I'm not I
like I like the EP. I like them. Maybe
you ought to learn more about the the
fascists that they protest.
So, let me let me thank you for having
the the guts and the bravery to to say
what you say. A comment and a question.
the uh 9/11 situation. They did not care
if they killed 10,000, 50,000, 100,000,
200,000, 1 million people. They didn't
care about that. It was irrelevant.
Someone told me that if I went to a
Muslim country, I'd be called a dimwit
or dehy or what is what is what is the
imitude? I don't understand that
concept. Could you explain it so that we
can understand what our rights would be?
Yes, I I would love to. And then Robert,
of course, we'll do the scholar will
take over. Demi Dimitude as coined by
the world's leading scholar on Islam in
the west Bat yayor. I strongly
recommend. I note that she's on all of
your curriculum in the syllabus. I'm
sure of it.
B A T Y E apostrophe o r. Uh to be a
demi is to live be allowed to live. It's
the third choice so to speak. You have
three choices in Islam. uh to convert to
submit to convert to die or to live
under demi status which is uh non-Muslim
living in a Muslim country you're denied
basic human rights it's a subclass
status uh you pay an exorbitant tax a
pole tax called uh the jiza say that
right thank you um and that's how they
funded most of their uh you know their
their their war games but I'm going to
let Robert really you should get the
best the
status of dimitude is founded on the
Quran chapter 9:29 which says fight
against those who do not believe in
Allah or the last day and do not forbid
what he has forbidden uh do not do not
obey Allah and his messenger rather
excuse me and do not forbid what he has
forbidden uh even if they are of the
people of the book until they pay the
jiza with willing submission and feel
themselves subdued. Now the people of
the book is the Quranic designation for
primarily Jews and Christians or anybody
with the revealed scripture. And the
Jiza as Pamela noted is a tax that has
to be paid with willing submission as
the the protected people so-called
that's what the word means feel
themselves subdued. This became the
foundation for an elaborate legal
superstructure in Islamic law that is
shared among the various schools of
Islamic Islamic juristprudence that
mandates a secondass status for
non-Muslims in the Islamic state. They
are not allowed to hold authority over
Muslims. They are not allowed to build
new houses of worship or to repair old
ones. They have to step off the street
like the old Jim Crow South if a Muslim
is coming. Uh these laws were abolished
in the Ottoman Empire in 1856 under
under western pressure but they remain
part of Islamic law as it is constituted
by all the various schools and part of
the goal of the Islamic jihad movements
around the world is ultimately to
institute the fullness of Islamic law
including these laws. They also remain
as a cultural hangover all around the
Islamic world to varying degrees such
that uh I know many uh non-Muslims from
Syria who have told me that uh they they
left Syria because they found that if
they went to get apply for certain jobs
they couldn't get them. Uh there was
there was a kind of quiet
discrimination. If you were a Christian
in Syria you could rise so high but no
higher. The Christians in Pakistan are
known by a derogatory nickname street
sweepers because that's the kind of jobs
that they have. Street sweepers, garbage
men, and so on. They can't get better
jobs because they're not allowed to hold
authority over Muslims.
Uh there is uh there there was there
were actually many incidents in Baghdad
of uh uh marauding bands of people
knocking on doors in Christian areas and
demanding payment, demanding the Jiza
because the state authority wasn't
enforcing it. But because they find it
in the Islamic scriptures, they believe
that it ought to be collected, ought to
be enforced. They found it a nice way to
make a little bit of a living. Uh, in
other words, these things are still very
much part of the uh, cultural
consciousness in very many parts of the
Islamic world. It's devilishly hard, so
to speak, to uh, get a permit to build a
church. Uh, synagogues aren't even on
the table since the Jews were expelled
from all the lands in the Middle East in
1948.
uh the churches. If you try to build a
church, even in secular Turkey, you run
into oceans of uh red ink and can't get
it can't get it done.
Yeah. Often times and uh the the in
systematic and ongoing harassment and
discrimination against the Coptic
Christians in Egypt is also a
manifestation of this. And so uh we need
to keep in mind that when the Imam Ra is
speaking about Sharia, this is part of
what he means.
Hi Mr. Spencer, I was about to actually
ask you to explain to the audience who
may have not read your books about your
about the Islamic doctrine on the
relationship between Islam and other
religions and in addition to treatment
of non-Muslims in the dimitude status
which you've just taken care of a lot.
So I'm going to modify that to can you
give us a document? People might think
that oh well that's just old stuff 14
centuries old. Can you give us a do a a
bit of an explanation of really the
track record and also what's going on
currently that's documented daily
occurrences in sites like uh gates of
Vienna or your site and the the
oppression in Pakistan the cops in Egypt
the how churches and people just
practicing their own religions in
Islamic countries are really treated
today you know as a as a sign because it
was mentioned Islamic respect for other
religions. Can we can we get a statement
of what the of the Islamic respect and
uh tolerance in action today? Can you
give us an opinion? Yeah, I'll give you
a couple of examples. Very recently,
just today, as a matter of fact, it was
in the news. I haven't been able to put
it up at Jihad Watch yet, uh but I will.
Uh there were uh there was an arrest in
Saudi Arabia
uh of 13 people who were daring to
celebrate a Roman Catholic mass.
And uh this is of course a very great
crime in Saudi Arabia because Muhammad
the prophet of Islam said on his
deathbed expel all the Jews and
Christians from Arabia. Now the Saudis
take that very seriously but in a very
legalistic way. They have thousands of
Filipino guest workers who are
Christians.
But as long as they do not practice
their faith in Saudi Arabia, then they
are welcome there. then they are not
considered to be Christians as such. But
if they dare to even possess a Bible or
a prayer book or rosary beads or
anything that is Christian, then they
are subject to arrest, deportation, even
long-term imprisonment. And there have
been many examples of this and the one
today is another. In Indonesia, just
last week, modern moderate Indonesia,
there were riots because there uh were
announced plans for Christians to build
a church.
It wasn't even a church, oddly enough,
where Christian extremists had
previously committed mass murder against
Muslims.
They didn't even want to build it on a
site like that. And of course, there's
so many sites like that.
No, this was just a church that the
people in the local area wanted to
build. The Muslims found out about it
and as I told you a minute ago under the
classic laws of dimitude Christians are
not allowed non-Muslims are not allowed
to build houses of worship in an Islamic
land and so there were riots and
killings and the people are in hiding
now and you know they ain't going to
build their church. This is the kind of
thing unfortunately that Christians face
on a more or less daily basis in places
like Egypt, Pakistan as well as
Indonesia.
and then you need to last question.
Okay. I'm want to ask you a question
about I mean the mosque question is
really you you're making a connection
between Islam as a whole and
um and this you know and 9/11 you say
there's a a connection between you say
you don't have anything against Muslims
except that their religion is is a
threat to the west in itself but I
I don't see how and please explain this
how you can hold a whole group
responsible for the actions of
individuals or what the relevance is of
things that happened a thousand years
ago and and the relevance too of this
one thing. I mean I don't mean to go on
and on. I got you but this is an
important point. Look, two weeks ago
they just finished an arms deal of $60
billion between the US government and
the government of Saudi Arabia. You
mentioned Pakistan. And then you also,
you know, mentioned Egypt. Look, Egypt's
the number two recipient of military aid
from the US. Look, with those two
countries, Saudi Arabia and Egypt, don't
even pretend to care about human rights.
That's correct. The case of 9/11, all
but one of the hijackers were Saudi. But
they don't have a war against the West.
The Saudi royal I'm sure they do. See,
this is this is the perils, my friends,
of believing your own propaganda. Your
propaganda sheet out there said that
we're doing all this. I'm not with them.
I'm Look, I'm US government. Uh, you
asked a question. I got the question.
I'm going to answer it. The propaganda
sheet out there said that we were doing
all this because of the American
military machine, you know, to justify
this. and we never say anything about
the Saudis or uh Hazi Mubarak. That's
ridiculous. I I I think that the idea
that the that Saudi Arabia is an ally of
the United States is a ridiculous and
ultimately possibly very lethal joke.
And I have no no interest in defending
the United States making arms deals with
Saudi Arabia or uh being a recipient uh
or Egypt being a recipient of US aid. I
think that is stupid. It's suicidal and
it's evil.
No question is who's the bigger threat
to world peace in this case and to
religious freedom? Is it the government
US for giving $60 billion worth of arms
to Saudi Arabia or is it that imam in
New York? Well, in so far as the
government of Saudi Arabia is using $60
million to finance the global jihad,
then obviously the government of Saudi
Arabia is a bigger threat. US the
government of the US. Yeah, we're
talking about the mosque here tonight.
You didn't ask me is this the biggest
threat facing the world today? Come on,
be serious. You you you asked me to come
here. Well, you didn't obviously, but uh
we were we were asked to come here to
talk about the mosque. We didn't come
here to talk about the mosque in any
sense of saying this is the biggest
problem facing the world today. Come on,
get off it. You you can't even believe
your own propaganda. You must not. Now,
as far as your first question goes, this
is very important and it has to be
addressed. The idea of demonizing all
Muslims, that's ridiculous. And nowhere
have I ever done this. This is just yet
another propaganda point. The idea is
this that Osama bin Laden and others
like him justify 9/11 and other attacks
like it on the basis of Islamic texts
and teachings. And as I said before,
they make their appeal to peaceful
Muslims in the Islamic world and in the
United States by presenting themselves
as the exponents of pure and true Islam.
That's what salafi means. They're the
pure one, the pure ones, the true ones.
And so that is a challenge that other
Muslims have to counteract. And the idea
that the Imam Raou is somebody who's
counteracting it when he's being so
deceptive, when he's being so dishonest,
and when he's openly propound uh
fronting for Sharia, well, I think, you
know, find yourself somebody better to
uh be the frontman for this. But the
fact is that if you are going to uh talk
about this realistically
all obviously all Muslims are not
responsible for anything. Nobody's
responsible for anything anybody else
does. I'm not responsible for what the
EDL does. And all Muslims are not
responsible. The only Muslims who are
responsible for 9/11 are the ones who
committed the act. But the question is,
if a Muslim believes in the same things
that led to 9/11,
then he is a matter of concern. He could
hurt you and you need to be aware of
that. And there are plenty more Muslims
than you obviously are aware of who
believe in exactly those same things
that Osama bin Laden believed because
those things the case that they make for
being the true and pure Muslims is a
very well-grounded case on the Quran and
Sunnah. I'm not saying it's absolutely
right. And I would be very happy if some
Muslim were to be able to construct some
version of Islam that was all about
peaceful coexistence and didn't have
those elements and was able to convince
vast numbers of Muslims that this was
the true Islam. But it ain't happening.
And so as long as it's not, we have to
just face this realistically.
And in so far as somebody like Rau is
prop is is is is propounding for Sharia
that's something that I am going to
stand up and say that is against human
rights that's against human dignity and
we have to stand and resist it
[Applause]
for having us today.
And um I just wanted to thank all of you
guys because uh do you realize what we
just did? We had a dialogue and that is
what Temple Excuse me.
We had a dialogue.
Without this opportunity, would this
have happened on Temple University's
campus? No. No
center exists at Temple University on
the 5th. Excuse me. You are the ones who
claimed to want to engage in dialogue
with me. You ambushed me. You You do not
believe.
Excuse me.
The religious studies club has no
credibility with me and you know that's
just the fact that's that was the first
impression. So,
so,
um, I want to thank everybody for coming
out and engaging in dialogue. Um, that's
the whole purpose of Temple University
purpose. And I want to thank again our
speakers, Pamela Geller and Robert
Spencer.
[Applause]
Good night.
Amen. who did and and we also militarily
funded because
so let me ask you a question
justifies what justifies Islamic mayhem
and murder in the world justifies
capitalist
[Music]
what did Khan do
we are we are we are
if you're happy to live here under our
democracy.
We would never
just racist. Totally wrong. Why are you
saying what? Isn't that Well, you're
totally wrong. And why a racist? How am
I a racist? You're making me to you.
You're a racist obvious.
[Music]
The United States is not an imperialist
country. We're not the main perpetrator
of violence.
That's going to sound the police
United States
perpetrators of violence police
department
like your Palestinian People to blow up.